bien aquí tenemos esta placa de
microcontrolador y quitaremos este
conector de aquí de hecho vamos a ver si
podemos quitar algunos conectores ya que
bueno la energía entra a esta placa a
través de estos dos conectores de aquí
fluye en este conector de aquí y en este
de aquí y hay una serie de diferentes
componentes y chips en esta placa así
que vamos a hablar de cada uno de ellos
y de lo que hacen observa que hay muchos
componentes y bueno de algunos no estoy
100% seguro de lo que son así que
trataré de hacer lo mejor posible este
de aquí según jon es un
oem prom que significa una memoria de
sólo lectura programable imborrable
eléctricamente que almacenan un índice
de órdenes para esta placa incluso
cuando la energía se apaga
entonces este chip de aquí que estoy
seguro que es la unidad central de
procesamiento y que controla todas las
funciones esta placa
la unidad completa básicamente lo que
pasa va consultando órdenes indexadas de
aquí hasta acá ya sabes hay una especie
de acceso a su memoria y luego tenemos
el chip del reloj este dvd tienda dentro
de él un pequeño cristal de cuarzo el
cual se obtiene una propiedad muy
interesante cuando se deforma puede
emitir pequeñas señales eléctricas o
cuando la electricidad pasa a través de
él se expande un poco y por esa razón es
muy estable en la manera en la que
responde a la electricidad es muy
estable en la manera en la que se
expande y por esta propiedad el cuarzo
es capaz de transmitir la electricidad a
él y conseguir que se expanda y después
regresar ese voltaje y determinar una
sincronización muy precisa de hecho es
el mismo temporizador que es utilizado
en los relojes de pulsera de cuarzo
de cualquier manera le permite a esta
placa sincronizarse lo que es muy
importante cuando estás leyendo
demasiada información del disco y bueno
tienes que asegurarte que todos estos
ceros y unos que tienen de toda esa
información vayan a terminar en un lugar
correcto y todo suceda de una manera
sincronizada y bueno como dije antes
esta es la unidad central de
procesamiento que controla la placa y
las funciones en ella creo que este chip
es el procesador de audio vídeo y una
vez que la información entra es dirigida
al cp1 a este chip y es procesada y
convertida en una señal que tu
televisión y tu exterior pueda entender
y todo gracias a este chip y bueno este
dakar es un amplificador operacional el
cual aumenta la señal que viene de este
chip tal vez la señal salga un poco
débil y bueno para que puedan viajar a
través de los cables que van a tu
televisión y a tu estéreo se necesita
aumentar la señal e incrementar el
voltaje y es justo lo que este chip
puede
y bueno este de acá es un chip
controlador de motor y lo que hace es
controlar la dirección y la velocidad de
los motores y lo hace de forma muy
precisa así que trabaja con el cpu para
asegurarse que los motores se estén
moviendo en la dirección y en la
velocidad correcta